you feeling this morning oh excellent
any symptoms you can go to the first
station right here to get help screen
you can go to the middle we could not do
this without volunteers
the sheer volume and number of folks
that we wanted to be able to serve and
bring in
requires as i said 320 individuals each
day to bring in
that volume so it requires volunteers to
support us because our hospitals right
now
are requiring all our nurses physicians
and other care providers
hold on please please hold on car coming
hey we have both clinical and
non-clinical volunteers
our non-clinical volunteers have been in
charge of
way finding helping people remain
socially distanced
they've helped with registration making
sure we sign people inappropriately
then i typically separate the ways
people and bring them over here
the idea that we would say well somehow
you don't um merit the same kind of
prevention
that we would give to the paid workers
it doesn't make any sense the system
doesn't
run without all all of these different
people in the role
so it makes perfect sense just like care
workers uh certain family caregivers in
some states
have been prioritized for vaccination it
makes sense to
to uh to prioritize all of the
vaccination center workers
for your dose too we will send you a
message on how to get that
cool so we have had 5 100
approximately 5 100 individuals who have
volunteered with us
many of those received their
vaccinations
with us they're considered 1a caregivers
when they assist
a thousand of those are repeat
volunteers so not only did they get
vaccinated but they've returned
several times in order to assist us i
volunteer just because i mean obviously
covet has been like a big problem around
the world
and like i want to help i want to be
part of the solution for it
and yeah i mean it was super rewarding
um
and like they're super efficient about
how they set everything up she's like
super impressed
uh i kind of just can't wait for this
all to be over